In today's video,
we are taking a look
at a common household spice,
and just how it reacts to fire.
Guys, you've probably
had cinnamon before.
You probably have
in your cupboard right now,
but did you know that cinnamon
is actually highly flammable?
To be more specific,
cinnamon is actually a dust
made from a bark of a tree,
and there's lots
of different types of it.
But dust itself is
highly explosive.
When you have these tiny
tiny little particles
of anything that's even
a little bit flammable,
when they're in air
in just the right ratio,
the flame can so easily travel
from one to the next
that it just blossoms out,
and can actually just
make an explosion.
In fact, in a lot
of food factories,
there are warnings everywhere
about potential explosions
due to the dust particles
in the air.
Cinnamon, soy products,
everything down to
custard powder can cause this.
Here's the basic idea.
We are taking a look at the hows
and whys of cinnamon ignition,
and then scaling it up.
One of the cool things
about cinnamon though is
that it doesn't burn quite
the same way as a lot
of other powders.
Lots of dry powders will burn
if they get thrown
into the air into a cloud,
and then come
in contact with heat.
But cinnamon has something
a little bit extra.
Not only does
cinnamon burn well,
and create a fireball
if it's combined with the air
in just the right ratio,
but it also has a cool
like magical effect,
where it makes the air look
like it's sparking,
and it's more than just a flame
when you burn a cinnamon.
So I actually learned
this trick years ago
at different bonfires
with my family.
But then, doing
some research on it,
I realize it's actually
pretty dangerous.
But we want to show you just
how cool it can be
under the right circumstances.
Cinnamon is actually
derived from a tree,
like we said.
It's actually the
inner tree bark.
So people will peel back the
outer layer of the tree bark,
and this is the layer
in between the actual tree
and the bark itself.
That's what cinnamon is.
It's wood, basically
this is sawdust.
Delicious, delicious sawdust.
But it's also very flammable,
just like most
wood products are.
So to begin with,
we're going to show
you a couple of really
small scale experiments
just to give you an idea
of what cinnamon
will do around a fire.
Now, we're not saying
that it's going to be explosive.
But this isn't something
that's going to detonate
if I put a flame on it.
Be really hard to bake with,
if that was the case.
But you can see
that it does burn
and catch fire.
[Music]
And it makes
the house smell amazing.
[Music]
So powdered sugar,
kind of the same as cinnamon
where it is technically a dust.
So it is explosive,
but it's not going to do
the same thing over the flame.
I'll show you.
[Music]
Not much.
But if you've ever
worked in the kitchen,
you will know that powdered
sugar, any type of sugar,
will catch fire.
This isn't doing anything
over the flame.
Look at the--
There we go.
They're in tiny bit.
Little tiny bit of orange fire.
That's it.
Maybe 1/4 of cinnamon,
compared to what we use
with the powdered sugar,
and it sparkles.
As it jets off,
you see the orange flame,
and then coming off
of the orange flame
is tiny little sparks,
and it looks so freaking cool.
So what Nate was doing before
at the powdered sugar?
You can see
the difference immediately.
So much more of a cinnamon.
Let me try and use
our cinnamon container
to sort of make clouds.
[Music]
And while it is explosive,
we're not doing this
in large enough quantities
for auto ignition.
What's happening here is
very very small clouds.
If we have these clouds
of cinnamon rising up so thick
that we couldn't see
6 inches from our face,
then we would technically
be in a danger zone.
Cinnamon dust is
highly flammable for
a couple of reasons.
Like we said,
this is basically
finely ground tree bark.
It's made of wood.
It's flammable, but it also
contains some other chemicals.
There are two chemicals
in cinnamon called
cinnamaldehyde and eugenol,
which are also
both very flammable,
and it's flammable enough
that it's possible
that cinnammon is actually
giving off vapors
that can burn as well.
So it's not just
the individual particles,
but of vapor itself coming
off of the cinnamon
that might burn.
So it's really cool
to see these effects,
even on a small scale
with our torch.
But now, we're going
to take it to the big level.
We want to show you guys what
this looks like in a bonfire.
With a lot of cinnamon.
A lot of cinnamon.
So much cinnamon.
Too much cinnamon.
There's no such thing.
Alright guys, we are out
in the middle of the desert now,
because we want to scale
up cinnamon in fire,
and show you just how cool
it looks in the bonfire,
but in safe conditions.
So Nate's built us
an awesome fire.
We're gonna light it up.
We could like this fire
with like matches,
but we like these.
[Music]
It was below 70 degrees,
so neither of us
were very happy.
This is better,
because I have a flare too,
but while we're waiting
for the fire to actually build,
we're going to
do something else.
Maybe ask for adult supervision
before trying this.
But as we were saying,
powdered sugar is
also highly flammable,
just not the same as cinnammon.
But it's a pretty
cool party trick.
[Music]
Also, it's delicious.
That's red.
I've never seen
this be red before.
I've never done this
with the road flare before.
Yum.
That's the fun thing
to do while waiting
for your bonfire to start.
All right.
Let's see if we can do this
with some regular fire.
The flare's making it red,
which is awesome.
I want to show you what it looks
like which has a regular flame.
[Music]
So this is going
to be cinnamon and sugar.
You guys have seen fireballs
just a powdered sugar.
Now, we're trying it
with the cinnamon.
I've never tried to breathe out
cinnamon into a fire before.
This will be interesting.
[Music]
That's delicious,
and my mouth is so dry.
[Music]
Oh, that's so cool.
Oh.
Good.
That's exactly what
you're supposed to do.
It is.
Did you spill it all down the--
That would be a yes.
As a side note,
Nate might have years
of experience of fire-breathing
in certain capacities,
and we also have taken
a lot of precautions.
We have a lot of water,
and an entire fire extinguisher,
and we're in the middle
of the desert.
So we're being pretty careful.
All right, we've got
a pretty good fire.
I don't think it's gonna get
much bigger than this.
No, this is perfect.
It might be time to start
throwing in some larger
quantities of cinnamon.
So you guys saw in the kitchen,
when we were just throwing
in a little tiny handfuls,
but now, with just
a couple of these,
after a handful of cinnammon,
if you want to grab a handful
of powdered sugar,
the powdered sugar makes
a really really big sort
of a fireball,
but the cinnamons going
to give it that sparkle.
3, 2, 1.
So they do react differently.
The sugar goes in--
Closer to the bottom.
There's a little bit
of a flare up.
So powdered sugar,
if you throw it
to the top of the flame
like you do with cinnamon.
Not much of a reaction.
If you toss it directly
into the flame.
That's when you're going
to get a bit of a flare.
Now, cinnamons the opposite.
If I throw it at the bottom,
you get kind of a flare,
but it's not going
to be quite the same.
At the top though.
You can get that really cool,
really fast fireball.
So we did sprinkles,
and now, we've moved on
to slightly larger handfuls.
So one thing I
do want to point out.
Nate and I are not standing in
any sort of dust cloud radius,
and we're also standing up wind
of the fire itself.
So we're not in any danger
where we're at,
so long as we toss the cinnamon
directly at the fire,
and not in our line of fire.
[Music]
3, 2, 1.
So I'm finding it interesting
to note that yes,
cinnamon is flammable.
But as you're seeing,
if we're tossing it
into the embers,
it's not doing much.
We've actually got a bit
of a trail of cinnamon
around our fire pit,
but it's not lighting.
Even though it's not,
we are going to douse
this entire area with water
before we leave.
[Music]
All right, we've got
one container left.
So I actually feel
pretty safe standing
where I am right now
as Nate's throwing,
because again, we're standing
up wind of the fire.
I have cinnamon on my clothes.
So I'm not going to get
any closer to the flames.
Although I'm not
in a dust cloud,
so I'm not in any danger.
If you've ever seen videos
of people covering
themselves in cinnamon.
There's one that went viral
around the internet
not too long ago.
That ended pretty badly,
but we're being very
very cautious here.
Another thing to note is
this entire area,
it smells so strong
we are cinnamon,
and it's amazing.
It's gonna smell that way here
for weeks, probably.
If you're going to experiment
with this at home,
make sure you have
an adult with you.
Make sure you're being
very very careful.
Don't coat yourself in cinnamon
before lighting a flame,
or anything like that.
That said, it can,
as we said,
cause explosions.
So if you decide to do this, do
it in a controlled environment,
make sure you have
safety precautions,
and then, have fun.
[Music]
Guys, that's not all.
You know we've always got more
for you to see.
This box up here at the top will
take you to our latest video.
And that box at the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit that bomb
so you can join the club,
and you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.